it is time to take control and optimize
your health at regenerate medical
concierge we stop by to learn more
about anti-aging
hi i'm dr amin and this is my office
regenerate medical concierge
we are primarily a anti-aging health and
wellness
clinic we do numerous things here
including
iv therapy hormone replacement but
anti-aging
specifically is actually a bit of a
misnomer
we can't technically reverse aging just
yet however another another term for it
is health and wellness
optimization and the goal there is
ideally to
slow down aging you know there's there's
a number of ways we can do that
one of them is using wrinkled relaxers
things like botox
dysport xeomin and these really just
help prevent wrinkles from forming by
preventing the the skin from moving the
other options include medications there
are certain meds that help our body
eliminate
cells that are not so healthy
or on their way to becoming not so
healthy we do our medically guided
weight loss
plans here specifically geared at
helping people
lose their fat concentration in the
bodies
while maintaining their muscle mass
some of the other things we can do is
genetic testing and
with the with the help of genetics we
can look at eliminating certain
components
of a person's lifestyle that for them
specifically
may not be as beneficial as they could
be for other people
and then one of the other components we
can look at is telomere testing
with technology today we can actually
look at how long a person's telomeres
are and the longer they are
the longer a person's lifespan can be
and there are medications
and various treatment plans that are
aimed specifically
at increasing the length of those
telomeres or maintaining their length
and lastly food allergy testing is
something we do where
what we're looking for is foods that
cause low levels of inflammation
you know most people uh know of the the
major allergies
uh where you eat peanuts or shellfish
and you know uh
turn into wolf smith from that movie
hitch right where everything puffs up
and so those are anaphylactic reactions
and there are also lower level reactions
where what's happening is
the foods you eat cause histamine
release and that chronic low level
is causing chronic inflammation
throughout the
the body and people just don't feel well
and by testing for
all the different types of foods
additives preservatives
antibiotics molds there's a whole
spectrum that can be tested over
350 different items and then we can
start
eliminating those things from the diet
we welcome you to come in
you can call our office and make an
appointment for a consultation
and that would be to sit with me and
discuss what's going on
the goal being to to figure out what
what the pinpoint
areas are and then getting the health
and wellness optimization plan rolling
out
thanks to regenerate medical concierge
for sponsoring this segment
give them a call at 702-998-8009 or
visit
regeneratemedicalconcierge.com las vegas